>>Dan St. Louis: All right,
good morning, everyone.
>>Teachers: Morning.
>>First, there was a conflict between
the two students in item nine yesterday.
Kind of came out of nowhere,
got real heated real quick.
Jess and Jackie sequestered
them, they both talked with me.
Megan?
>>Meghan Rosa: How about if
I meet with them every day
after school for like five minutes?
>>Dan St. Louis: We don't have
kids falling through the cracks
because we meet every single
week and address what's going on.
There's nothing quite like
getting everyone in a room,
getting everyone's brains
on the same issue right now
and coming up with a solution.
>>We have a really diverse
urban population and the range
of issues we have to deal with,
whether it's in the classroom,
outside the classroom, is a wide range.
>>Kaitlin Kelley: We know
that these kids have a lot
of stuff going on in their lives.
They're going to have
trouble not just academically,
but socially, emotionally, behaviorally.
They have a lot of issues, so
we need to figure out a way
that we can fix those problems
and not give up on them.
So our culture is basically,
no problem is too big.
>>Lauren Mills: So we have
a regular team meeting
on Wednesday mornings every week.
>>Dan St. Louis: When we
build the schedule every year,
we do whatever we need
to do to keep that time,
because we know how important it is.
>>Lynnel Reed: It's a
chance to share information
about students in a problem solving way.
>>Dan St. Louis: So that takes
care of items one through six.
>>It is agenda driven so
that we can stay on track.
There might be as few as ten agenda
items or as many as twenty some weeks,
just things that we need to address.
>>To the final item on today's agenda,
could someone let me know
what exactly was going
on with some of this online drama?
>>Teacher: Yeah, in my journalism
class, I heard a couple of the girls
and guys talking about
how they are chatting
with people on an online dating site.
That was a bit of a warning for
me and I talked to some of them.
Mainly talking to them, was more like,
"That's crazy, get off, don't do that."
>>Dan St. Louis: Right, stay away.
They think they're just chatting?
>>Teacher: That's what they think.
I mean, that's what they're saying.
>>Kaitlin Kelley: All right, now what
are we going to do about the problem?
That's where somebody usually
steps up and comes up with a plan
or we establish a plan,
and then it's delegation.
Who's going to be responsible
for the follow through?
So for the issue of social
media, our faculty decided
that it might best be handled by our
students, actually, our peer mediators.
>>Dan St. Louis: That's a good
message for the peer mediator group.
Is this something that
we can pull off, Lauren?
>>Lauren Mills: I think that they
could easily get together a group
of the peer mediators to talk
about like social media safety.
>>Kaitlin Kelley: Sometimes hearing it
from a student perspective
is better for our kids.
>>Student: In such a small town, so
many people know each other and that's
when the gossip comes around.
>>Student: When it goes out, even though
someone says, "Oh, it's only there
for five seconds to ten seconds," but
in reality, it stays there forever.
>>Teacher: What about if
they make a racist joke
and they're just not
mature enough to recognize
that there's an audience that's much
bigger than them and their story?
>>Student: Before you
put it on the screen,
you've got to think about
what is the outcome?
>>Student: So that's one thing
we want to really attack is,
how it can affect their future
and how like, even the things
that they do now can last forever.
>>Lauren Mills: The problem
solving structure here really is,
I think, of mutual accountability.
Everyone takes responsibility
for solving student problems.
>>Dan St. Louis: Our kids see
themselves as problem solvers
and see themselves as
keepers of the culture.
So they're going to put together a
workshop for the middle schoolers
about what's going on online,
what's the kind of okay stuff to do,
where do you have to be careful?
>>Student: Vin and I
will be doing a Snapchat.
When Vin and I present a Snapchat,
we'll say, "Who would like a volunteer."
>>Dan St. Louis: And hopefully that
reaches them when it's someone closer
to their own age saying it.
>>Student: We are the peer mediators
and our topic is going
to be about social media.
>>Student: Colleges look at your
Facebook, they look at your Twitter,
so it's really important to keep in mind
that it's not just your
friends looking at it.
>>Dan St. Louis: Because we do
so much team problem solving,
our kids know that they're not alone.
They know that a team of smart
adults are on their side.
>>Teacher: We tried to get to
the root of what was going on....
>>Dan St. Louis: That no
problem is too big or too bad
to be addressed in some way.
It doesn't mean that we can
fix everything tomorrow,
but nothing can't be addressed.
>>Teacher: That's great news.